here's what you didn't know about the
AT&T commercial girl
everybody loves Lillie att's perky
enthusiastic commercial spokeswoman
based on her TV ads we know she's nerdy
and awkward a hopeless romantic and she
likes bedazzling but how much do you
actually know about the lady behind the
lily here's what you may not have known
about the a TMC commercial girl mallanna
Vayntrub this might blow your mind but
Lily's name isn't actually Lily it's
actually mallanna alexandrovna Vayntrub
Vayntrub was born in the u.s. Beck's
Soviet Socialist Republic or what's now
the Republic of Uzbekistan you know what
they say give us your tired your poor
and your huddled masses yearning to
become Hollywood pop-culture sensations
political refugee life in the USSR
wasn't exactly sunshine and rainbows for
the faint reps especially because they
face persistent religious persecution
for being Jewish in an officially
atheist country when mallanna was 2 her
family fled Uzbekistan in hopes of
finding religious freedom and political
asylum in America the process was long
and grueling with the family stranded in
both Austria and Italy for a while
luckily the Vayntrub made it to America
and settled in California which sounds
like a wonderful step up Barbie and ER
Lilly is hardly the first character
faint rub ever played in a commercial
she began acting in TV ads at five
starring in Barbie commercials to help
her family make ends meet her first big
break happened in 1995 when she landed a
guest spot on ER where she appeared
alongside stars like julianna margulies
at the precocious and precious age of a
high school dropout Vayntrub attended
Beverly Hills High School but she
dropped out as a sophomore but not
because she didn't value her education
she actually wanted to learn more
quickly Vayntrub got her GED and moved
on to the University of San Diego where
she earned a degree in communications
appropriate considering she's known for
selling AT&T products UCB grad The
Upright Citizens Brigade is one of the
most famous comedy troupes in show
business Vayntrub honed her comedy chops
with the UCB joining other famous
graduates like Saturday Night Live bets
Kate McKinnon Bobby Moynihan and Horatio
Sanz to name a few she may not have made
the SNL cast yet
but her work with the UCB helps explain
her comedic timing
YouTube sensation Vayntrub has
guest-starred on shows like key & peele
Californication and Silicon Valley but
before all that she rose to prominence
through a different channel on YouTube
as one of the co-creators of live prude
Girls Vayntrub was an early YouTube
sensation with each of her videos
earning hundreds of thousands of views
the channel is dormant now but if you
want a sneak peek at life before Lilly
you can still watch Vayntrub hit videos
online bonus points if you watch from an
AT&T device the can't do nothing
movement Vayntrub created the can't do
nothing movement which has spurred
nearly a quarter of a million people
worldwide to use social media to help
crusade for the rights of refugees
around the globe saving the world by
using your AT&T phone to record YouTube
videos of yourself helping refugees
that's just the kind of moment that
Lilly would absolutely love thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one
you just saw and leave us a comment and
share your favorite Lilly moment